another great way of getting data in
data science is by scraping data
this is important because not all data
comes in nice json formats
not all data is built for access and so
sometimes you have to get creative in
how you access the data
for instance i can include html text on
a web page or tables on wikipedia or pdf
documents or media like
images and video and audio and so on
also there's word documents and there's
powerpoint presentations
and any number of sources that have data
that do not come in a nice package for
importing into python or
are be aware of issues of copyright and
confidentiality
this data was not created for you to
scrape and sometimes there are reasons
why it's been restricted
you need to be aware of what the
restrictions are and to respect those
and operate professionally
if you want to scrape data you have a
couple of choices
one is use ready-made tools for instance
import.io that's both a web address
and it's the name of a tool that makes
scraping data from web pages very easy
scraper wiki and tabula also make this
easy
in fact in google sheets you can simply
use the equals and porthmo underscore
command to pull data
out of a table and even some versions of
excel make this possible
or you can use custom tools you can
scrape data through our
python java or php
any of these will make it possible for
you to access data and manipulate it in
the ways that you need to get it into an
analyzable format
in conclusion scraping works when apis
don't exist for the data that you want
to work with
also you can use specialized apps that
were created for scraping
or you can code in your language of
choice
finally copyright and confidentiality
issues matter
and they should always be considered
carefully before you start scraping data
off the web